[Applaus]
[Musik]
die mongolei ist eines jener länder von
denen wir alle gehört haben über die
hier aber praktisch nichts wissen
[Musik]
das klima des zweitgrößten land der welt
ist eben so unwirklich wie feindselig
die winter können bis zu minus 40 grad
celsius kalt werden und sind manchmal so
hart dass nicht einmal das einheimische
fiel ihnen standhalten kann im winter
2009 sind zum beispiel achteinhalb
millionen rinder an der kälte verendet
das ist ein fünftel des gesamten
bestands des landes
[Musik]
dir vorstellen kannst ist die mongolei
kein ort an dem das leben müssen was
einfach ist tatsächlich hat das extreme
klima dazu geführt dass sich im laufe
der geschichte nur wenige menschen in
diesem land niedergelassen haben und
obwohl das territorium fast dreimal so
groß ist wie zb spanien oder nur wenig
kleiner als mexiko übersteigt seine
bevölkerung kaum drei millionen
einwohner das heißt wir sprechen über
einen der am dünnsten besiedelten orte
auf diesen planeten und außerdem auch
einem der ärmsten aber liebe visapolitik
fensters schicksal der mongolei könnte
sich eigentlich wenden zumindest
existiert eine riesen chance und das
alles dank des gigantischen schatzes der
sich in den tiefen dieses landes
verbirgt
die mongolei ist nämlich messen anderen
bodenschätzen eines der reichsten länder
der welt wir sprechen hier von kupfer
gold uran erdöl ein e mails
rohstoffreichtum und eine relativ kleine
bevölkerung wen erinnert das nicht an 1
bettelarme und heute stinkreiche länder
wie dubai oder noch wegen genau aus
diesem grund machte sich die mongolische
regierung zu beginn dieses jahrhunderts
unter ausnutzung der wirtschaftlichen
anziehungskraft ist ungemein
rohstoffhungrigen china aus daran diesen
enormen reichtum endlich auszubeuten auf
diese weise wurde die mongolei zu einer
vielversprechenden bergbau macht die
wenig überraschend etwa 90 prozent ihrer
produktion in die volksrepublik china
exportiert und innerhalb weniger jahre
stunde geld in das land oder das
wirtschaftswachstum erreichte über zehn
prozent pro jahr die zukunft sah
vielversprechend aus in ein paar jahren
könnte die mongolei in den club der
reichsten länder asiens aufsteigen aber
mittlerweile schreiben sie ja bereits
das jahr 2022 es hängt also sich die
frage zu stellen ist die mongolei
tatsächlich ein reiches und wohlhabendes
land geworden nun ja wenn du denkst dass
man in ulan bator der hauptstadt des
landes in der mehr als die hälfte der
landesbevölkerung leben wasser durch
champagner und die traditionelle die
mäntel durchschnitte armani anzüge
ersetzt hat die zu total daneben
[Musik]
leicht verdientes geld muss nämlich
nicht unbedingt glück bringen und wenn
praktisch ein ganzes geschäft von einem
einzigen kunden abhängt kann seine
position vor dem schwach und unsicher
seien die frage lautet also was genau
ist in der mongolei passiert was gut
auch wenn diese geschichte ist genauso
interessant und lehrreich wie
überraschend und spannt
[Musik]
die mongolische morgendämmerung
ok schauen wir mal diese grafik an
was du hier siehst ist die entwicklung
des pro kopf bip in der mongolei einem
sehr armen land dessen wirtschaft
traditionell mit einer sehr rudimentären
arts viehzucht und landwirtschaft
verbunden ist außerdem hat der
zusammenbruch des kommunistischen blocks
der mongolei einen schweren
wirtschaftlichen schlag versetzt zur
erinnerung bis 1992 war die mongolei
eines satelliten start der sowjetunion
und ja ist diese zusammenbrach wurde
einen übergang zu einem demokratischen
modell der freien marktwirtschaft
eingeleitet aber viele der politischen
und produktiven strukturen aus der
kommunistischen ära blieben erhalten
der notwendige privatisierungsprozess
fiel zu allem überfluss jedoch auch eher
suboptimal aus wie in vielen anderen
postkommunistischen ländern leidet auch
die mongolei unter dem phänomen der
extremen oligarch welche sich die
ehemaligen stars unternehmen zu
schnäppchenpreisen unter den nagel riss
um die wirtschaft wieder anzukurbeln und
der postsowjetischen krise entkommene
verabschiedete die regierung 1997 das
bergbaugesetz und weißt du was dieser
schritt sollte alles verändern
das gesetz sollte private investitionen
im bergbausektor ist besondere von
ausländischem kapital fördern ein sektor
der bis dahin hauptsächlich von kleinen
produzenten mit sehr wenig vitalisierung
beherrscht wurde und so vergab die
mongolische regierung zwischen 1997 und
2002 fast 3000 explorationslizenzen für
die erschließung neuer minen
[Musik]
und achtung die erteilten lizenzen
umfassen fast vier prozent der
gesamtfläche des landes eines
gigantischen landes wir sprechen hier
von mehr als 60.000 quadratkilometern
land das uns etwas mehr als 25 prozent
der gesamten fläche eines staates wie
großbritannien welche in die hände von
bergbaufirmen gelegt wurden und in den
meisten diese lizenzen sind nicht bei
unternehmen aus jedem land gelandet an
dass er ist alle denkt schau dir mal die
namen einiger dieser unternehmen an der
mongolia and resource corporation kobe
resources corporation
international die klingen nicht
besonders chinesisch oder der grund
warum sie nicht chinesisch klinge ist
dass sie es nicht sind die meisten
unternehmen die lizenz zur erkundung und
ausbeutung des moralischen untergrunds
erhalten haben kommen aus kanada und
australien einige wenige aus
großbritannien der schweiz und
verschiedenen anderen ländern in vielen
fällen will diese unternehmen joint
ventures mit der mongolischen regierung
selbst so dass die regierung nicht nur
durch steuern und lizenzgebühren dann
auch durch ihren eigenen anteil am
gewinn von dieser tätigkeit profitierte
das alles sei also wie ein ideales
geschäftsumfeld aus eine win win
situation wie aus dem lehrbuch umso mehr
als fast alle mineralien wie abgebaut
wurden gar nicht weit transportiert
werden mussten sondern nur über die
grenze zum großen nachbarn china
exportiert wurden vor allem in die eisen
und stahl produktionszentren des reiches
der mitte welche eisen kohle und andere
mineralien verbrauchten als gäbe es kein
bohren
[Musik]
der optimismus war überwältigend in nur
wenigen jahren stiegen die ausländischen
investitionen von etwa zehn millionen
dollar in den frühen neunziger jahren
auf über 800 millionen dollar auf dem
höhepunkt des booms im jahr 2008 auch
die exporte stiegen zwischen 2003 und
2008 um das fünffache auf mehr als 1,8
milliarden dollar und vergesst nicht
dass wir hier über ein land mit etwas
mehr als drei millionen einwohner
sprechen prokop ausgedrückt sind das
also enorme zahlen vor allem wenn wir
bedenken dass die mongolei eines der
ärmsten länder der welt war
aber das sollte sich bald ändern denn
jetzt floss das geld in strömen und das
bip wuchs rasend schnell in nur einem
jahrzehnt verzehnfachte sich die größere
wirtschaft plötzlich schossen
investitionsprojekte aller art aus dem
boden und bauprojekte über schwänzen das
land die zukunft der mongolei so rosig
aus dann aber von einem tag auf den
anderen hörte alles auf den mongolen
wuchs nicht mehr es wurde nicht mehr
investiert und das land viel in eine
chronische stagnation und die frage ist
was um alles in der welt ist passiert
wieso ging auf einmal alles den bach
runter genau das schauen wir uns erst
einmal an
[Musik]
wer auffällt oder politik sale
eines ist klar der bergbau boom brachte
der mongolei bedeutende vorteile die bis
heute anhalten daran gibt es keinen
zweifel
trotzdem ist die frustration mehr als
offensichtlich die krise von 2008 hat
das ganze auf bergbau im turbogang fußen
die mongolische wirtschaftsmodell in
seine schranken verwiesen
[Musik]
der grund weil hatte zu 100 prozent auf
schnelles wachstum und hoher
rohstoffpreise gesetzt alle
investitionen wurden auf die möglichst
schnelle ausbeutung der vorkommen
zugeschnitten sodass ein stetig hohes
niveau der rohstoffpreise vorausgesetzt
wurde das war optimal für jeden
zeitabschnitt in denen die rohstoffe
sehr teuer waren es wurden jedoch keine
vorkehrungen fall netze und reserven
gebildet falls die rohstoffpreise mal
einbrechen sollten
die wirtschaftliche rezession brachte
den investitions und exportboom zu
stillstand denn die nachfrage und die
preise für wichtige mineralien brachen
ein der kupferpreis zb viel von rund
8000 dollar pro tonne im jahr 2007 auf
rund 2.500 dollar ein rückgang von fast
70% und praktisch das gleiche passierte
mit den anderen rohstoffen was bedeutet
dass die regierung einen ihrer
wichtigsten einnahmequellen verlor
plötzlich verwandelten sich die
überschüsse und defizite vor allem in
der handelsbilanz der mongolei hatte
sich auf den export ihrer bergbau
produkte spezialisiert und gleichzeitig
die importe massiv hochgefahren
denn die einnahmen sprudelten ja nur so
irgendwie ging man davon aus dass es
ewig nur bergauf gehen würde oder man
irgendwie rechts hat sich von irgendwem
gewarnt wurde dabei wissen wir doch
schon seit das eichhörnchen gibt das ist
immer auf und ab geht der gute alte
schweinezyklus eben deswegen muss man in
guten zeiten vorsorgen und reserven
bilden welche einen dann durch die
schlechten zeiten bringen dieses
fahrlässiges versäumnis hat natürlich
die staatsverschuldung und vor allem die
auslandsverschuldung geradezu
explodieren lassen sie beträgt derzeit
240 prozent der wirtschaftsleistung
relativ gesehen ist das die höchste
auslandsverschuldung der welt
die mongolei fiel der sogenannten
holländischen krankheit zum opfer über
die wir bereits mehrere videos gemacht
haben dh die bergbauindustrie ließ
kapital ins land strömen trieb sowohl
die preise als auch den lokalen
wechselkurs in die höhe und weil die
produktivität der unternehmen im
allgemeinen sehr niedrig war führten
steigende arbeitskosten und
unaufhaltsame wechselkurs dazu dass
viele dieser lokalen unternehmen in
konkurs gingen die mongolische
wirtschaft wurde dadurch in hohem maße
vom rohstoffsektor abhängig und als die
rohstoffpreise zusammenbrachen hatten
wir alle zutaten für den perfekten sturm
aber das ist noch nicht alles meine
lieben zuschauer einem bericht der
weltbank zufolge hat die mongolei seit
2004 mineralien im wert von 28
milliarden dollar gefördert daraus hat
der staat in den letzten 15 jahren 9
milliarden dollar an steuern und
gebühren eingenommen gleichzeitig hat
die regierung jedoch fast den gleichen
betrag nämlich 8,7 milliarden dollar an
schulden aufgenommen diese kredite
wurden dabei durch zukünftige einnahmen
aus rohstoffexporten abgesichert vergiss
nicht dass wir über ein sehr armes land
mit einer sehr kleinen bevölkerung
sprechen für die das eine riesige menge
geld ist im jahr 2009 10 das machen sich
jedoch kaum 200 millionen dollar in der
staatskasse 200 millionen dollar von den
fast 18 milliarden die seit 2004 mit
mineralien exporten angehäuft wurden und
erinnert ihr euch noch daran dass ich
gesagt habe der staatshaushalt sei
bereits nach der krise im jahr 2008 in
die roten zahlen gerutscht das ist schon
gut 14 jahre her und trotzdem steckt
erst seit den immer noch in den miesen
die berechtigte frage ist also was die
mongolische regierung eigentlich mit dem
ganzen geld gemacht hat was ist gut auf
denn hier wird die geschichte so richtig
interessant
[Musik]
okay wie du dir vorstellen kannst
spielte korruption eine wichtige rolle
die mongolei ist nicht das
transparenteste land der welt und
deswegen war es sehr schwierig das wahre
ausmaß der korruption einschätzen zu
können durch liegt wie zum beispiel die
pendler peters wurde jedoch bewiesen
dass der ehemalige premierminister zum
beispiel gerne immobilien in der ganzen
welt kaufte trotz alldem der schlüssel
um herauszufinden wo all die vielen
milliarden gelandet sind liegt nicht in
dieser art von korruption vielmehr haben
wir es mit einem phänomen zu tun welches
auch in etablierten demokratien als
normal hingenommen wird massiver
stimmenkauf die bestechung der wähler
durch die politiker mit deren eigenem
steuergeld natürlich ist in der
mongolischen politik praktisch
institutionalisiert worden der
derzeitige präsident auch nadine krause
kamen beispielsweise mit dem slogan an
die macht die mongolei hat ihre
rohstoffe oder ihre eigenen kontrolle
doch anstatt an investitionsplänen für
die industrie oder in einem politischen
projekt zur ankurbelung der wirtschaft
zu arbeiten bestand die erste maßnahme
die der präsidenten nach seinem
amtsantritt ergriff darin rentner mit
geld zu überschütten das war auch sein
großes wahlversprechen gewesen die mit
zukünftigen rohstoffeinnahmen
gesicherten kredite an die pulsion ehre
des landes auszuschütten klar die sind
ja auch die zukunft des landes aber
[Musik]
spaß beiseite der grund war natürlich
dass rentner die mit abstand wichtigste
wählergruppe der mongolei darstellt
erstens weil es sehr viele von ihnen
gibt zweitens weil sie gemeinsame
interessen haben und drittens weil ihre
wahlbeteiligung viel höher ist als die
der übrigen wähler sie bilden die
stärkste lobby der mongolei ihr einfluss
ist enorm und passt gut auf denn wir
reden hier nicht über eine absolute
ausnahme ein einzelfall diese art
politik zu machen ist für alle
politischen parteien die norm geworden
sie sind quasi zu einer großen
blockpartei verschmolzen deren agenda
nur darin besteht die wähler durch
kurzfristige verlockungen zu
korrumpieren auf der jagd nach der
nächstbesten wählerstimme
die entsprechenden ausschlaggebenden
wählergruppen sind diese um süchtig
geworden nach den süßen wahlgeschenken
und haben den rest der bevölkerung quasi
in geiselhaft genommen die zukunft wird
von frühstückt ein teufelskreis der sich
in den letzten 14 jahren in eine späte
abda spirale entwickelt habt und ja
etwas ähnliches könnte er hilft fast
jedem land der welt passieren aber
nirgendwo sonst würde der kauf von
stimmen mit versprechungen von hartem
geld so perfektioniert und auf die
spitze getrieben wie in der asiatischen
steppe nicht einmal im der pleite land
argentinien um die eine vorstellung
davon zu geben von den 3,2 millionen
einwohnern der mongolei erhalten zwei
millionen regelmäßige staatliche
unterstützung die politischen parteien
brauchen keine intelligenten wähler die
kritisch denken können sie brauchen arme
unmündige wähler die sich leicht mit
geld manipulieren lassen wenn es sein
muss gerät ob er in belek
politikwissenschaftler an der
mongolischen national university of
education mit anderen worten dem
mongolischen politiker haben den
rohstoffreichtum genutzt um an die macht
zu kommen und ein perfides system von
elio kratie zu errichten aber das
problem ist nun mal dass irgendwann
jeder kuh die milch ausgeht weit davon
entfernt die entwicklung produktive
wirtschaftszweige anzukurbeln unter
einem staatsfonds aufzubauen der in
zukunftsindustrien investiert haben die
mongolischen politiker die vergangenen
gegenwärtigen und sogar den
überwiegenden großteil des zukünftigen
bodenschätze ihres landes dafür verpasst
links rechts und in der mitte straße zu
verteilen dass im grunde genommen nur
dazu da ist die vollkommen überzogenen
importe zu finanzieren an welche sich
die bevölkerung den effekten jahre
gewöhnt hatte
[Musik]
und ich betone hier ausdrücklich das
wörtchen zukünftig weil kredite er eines
tages zurückgezahlt werden müssen echte
reformen sind jedoch nicht in sicht der
natürliche reichtum hat der mongolei die
chance geben ein sehr reiches land zu
werden doch die politische kiel hat sich
dieses traumes beraubt aber ist bist du
an der reihe hast du jemals daran
gedacht das natürliche ressourcen einen
flug sein könnten welche mechanismen
würdest du in deine politik einbauen um
eine solche fatale entwicklung zu
verhindern wie immer sind auf eure
meinung zu diesem thema schon gespannt
ich hoffe also dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat was ja gibt es mit einem
like teilt das mit euren freunden
vergesst nicht dass aber mit glück
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
unterstützt unsere arbeit wird auch mit
einer kleinen spende über den link in
der beschreibung unter diesem video was
gut und bis bald
[Musik]